pendant ce long week end de noël les
enfants et les jouets sont rois et parmi
les cadeaux que le père noël apporte
dans sa hotte
la tradition voulait qu'il y ait
toujours un martinet la tradition se
perd moins qu'on ne le croit il reste
des parents et même beaucoup qui sont
convaincus des bienfaits de la gifle de
la fessée et même du coup de trique
lorraine cuse et me tiens voilà vraiment
elle l'a cherché
et puis il faut dire que ça soulage les
parents exaspérés
rien de tel que cette thérapeutique
millénaire pratiquer encore par plus de
la moitié des familles qui dans notre
enfance on n'a pas reçu jean mercier
certainement il comme clients en france
et n'a pas marqué non les ma fille en
dessous quelques gris nez elle est pas
un gros bug ça peut le faire que du bien
un enfant ça se dresse nous disait ton
il fallait briser ses penchants
naturellement indisciplinés bref qu'ils
devaient obéir et les enfants maintenant
on en trouve guère il est vrai qu'ils
contestent le droit des parents à punir
le sont traumatisés par cette fessée à
vertus morales indiscutable enfin
presque indiscutable
on pourrait pas les battre mais les
punir de quelque chose qu'ils aiment
bien par exemple d'une émission à la
télé ou alors d'autres choses ou alors
je ne sais pas où dans loisirs qu'ils
aiment bien au lieu de les taper taper
comme sade si ça peut faire qu'aggraver
les choses
pourtant 50 % des adeptes du châtiment
corporel corrigent leurs progénitures
plusieurs fois par mois un tir au moins
une fois par semaine et la main ne
suffit pas toujours
il y à la chaussure la ceinture le
martinet 28% des punisseur
[Musique]
un peu trop cruel de nouveautés avec de
vrais morceaux de pierre cohen devrait
pas exister
de plus en plus en cette saison
particulièrement vous voyez le père noël
doit en apporter en principe
qu'est ce qu'ils disent les parents
quand ils en achètent pensée pour leur
chien sait jamais pour les gosses